think it's all just CGI and production
tricks that bring your favorite
superheroes to life on screen from
damaged vocal cords to Broken Bones to
an actual death on set you won't believe
how dangerous playing a superhero can
actually be Jamie Alexander who plays
the warrior lady Sif in the Thor
franchise suffered various injuries
while filming Thor the Dark World
luckily the film's production could work
around her giving the actor time to
recuperate without delaying the
production of the movie Alexander was an
athlete in her youth so she carried that
physical prowess with her into her
acting career and has always been
willing to do her own stunts I've got
this
control
describing the injuries she suffered on
the set of Thor the Dark World Alexander
told page six it was raining it was dark
outside it was like five in the morning
I went down a metal staircase and
slipped and slipped a disc in my
thoracic spine and chipped 11 of my
vertebrae I knocked my left shoulder out
of place and tore my rhomboid on my
right side it took me out of filming for
a month these severe injuries didn't
stop Alexander from reprising her role
in the Thor franchise nor did they keep
her from taking on another stunt
intensive role when she agreed to play
Jane Doe in blind spot she also
sustained numerous injuries from her
stunt work on that series despite the
pain she loves doing her own stunts and
takes pride in her physical endurance
no centeneo has enjoyed major success in
recent years thanks to his lead role in
Netflix's the recruit and his
performance as Adam Smasher in Black
Adam but this Triumph comes with costs
centeneo told Jimmy Fallon on The
Tonight Show that he suffered a pretty
painful injury while shooting a scene as
Adam Smasher under the sweltering
Atlanta sun he explained that he was
trying to add some Flair to the scene by
pretending to hit his knee on a parked
car while he was running and I like spin
around lines ah I like that hurt my arm
goes up and then dislocates
[Laughter]
medic struggled to get centineo's
shoulder back in its socket due to his
tight costume filming was paused as they
cut the sleeve open after 13 tries they
finally popped his shoulder back in only
for centeneo to immediately pop it back
out by lifting his arm to cheer luckily
his shoulder was easier to fix the
second time although it's a fairly minor
injury in the grand scheme of things
production ground to a halt while the
Medics dealt with centeneo and the
Wardrobe Department surely had to
replace his damaged suit Robert Downey
Jr might seem Invincible on screen but
he actually broke his ankle while
filming a stunt for Iron Man 3. Guy
Pierce who played Aldrich Killian in the
film revealed further details to GQ
Robert broke his ankle in the middle of
that film because he had to do his stunt
where he had to jump from one platform
down to another platform and be on a
cable they wanted to rehearse it and he
said no I don't need to rehearse it and
he jumped and the guy holding the cable
wasn't ready or something and he'd
landed hard interestingly enough the
take were down he broke his ankle
actually made it into the movie after
the film was done Downey told media
Outlets his body held up fine and joked
that the delay in production gave them
an opportunity to work on the script and
make Iron Man 3 into a better movie I
did all right I broke my echo once but
then that gave us time to uh do some
more script Provisions believe it or not
Chris Evans almost turned the iconic
role of Captain America down but once he
was on board Evans embraced The role's
More Physical aspects even doing some of
his own stunts in Captain America the
First Avenger the actor told MTV News
the good thing about cap is that most of
his abilities are rooted in what a human
being is capable of he's not flying he's
not shooting fire for the most part the
stunts involved were hand-to-hand combat
so anytime I can put the gloves on and
get in the ring I'll do it unfortunately
Evans injured his arm while filming
Captain America's Civil War in a pivotal
scene Steve Rogers tries to stop a
helicopter from taking off with his bare
hands Evans told Entertainment Tonight
that was in the first week of filming
and I actually messed up my arm doing it
I really did it's a fake helicopter
obviously but it was drifting Beyond the
ability of control I tweaked a little
something to this day I'm still messed
up notably Robert Downey Jr wasn't
surprised by this injury when he arrived
at the Civil War set and saw what Evans
had been filming the actor immediately
knew that this shot was risky luckily
after Evan sustained his injury Downey
was there to help
Hugh Jackman has suffered a Litany of
injuries playing Wolverine over the
years
objection of X-Men Jackman smashed his
ear and in a separate instance injured
his groin after getting caught in a
stunt harness the actor told Yahoo that
was pretty brutal I screamed so much and
they kept going because they figured it
was me Primal yellow moating then during
the production of X2 X-Men United
Jackman discovered just how dangerous
Wolverine's metal claws truly are when
he cut the skin next to his eye which
left a scar and his upper thigh Jackman
talked about the ladder injury on The
Graham Norton Show explaining that it
happened while filming a nude scene he
turned a corner saw a group of female
crew members who had gathered together
as a joke to surprise and embarrass him
and reflexively tried to cover himself
of course the first thing I did was I
[Laughter]
was like external injuries aren't the
only type Jackman experienced while
playing Wolverine during an interview
with the BBC he admitted I've done some
damage to my voice with Wolverine my
falsetto is not as strong as it used to
be and that I directly put down to some
of the growling and yelling my vocal
teacher in drama school would have been
horrified with some of the things I did
Jason Momoa suffered multiple injuries
while filming Aquaman and the lost
kingdom telling Ellen DeGeneres that he
scratched his cornea during production
and that's just for starters he
elaborated I messed up my eyes just got
something in it that kind of cut it up
and I got to get surgery on a hernia I
got ribs out I'm just getting beat up
Momoa assured degenerous the injuries
were well worth it however saying it's
gonna be a great movie you're gonna love
it the generous playfully gave Mamoa a
hard time for getting injured in every
movie he seems to make Mamoa chalked it
up to his advancing age and passion for
filmmaking it's rough stuff but he
considers it worth it like many movies
affected by the kova 19 pandemic the
Batman saw its fair share of
difficulties during production some of
them even predated the pandemic star
Robert Pattinson told GQ I broke my
wrist at the beginning of it all doing a
stunt even before covid so the whole
first section was trying to keep working
out looking like a penguin I remember
when that seemed like the worst thing
that could go wrong soon the film was
shut down because of the pandemic giving
patents in plenty of time the nurse his
broken wrist and quarantine with the
rest of the world then after the movie
finally went back into production with
new regulations patents and tested
positive and production was paused again
the Batman shoot ultimately encompassed
a staggering 18 months leaving the star
feeling beleaguered and burned out in
the end breaking his wrist during a
stunt turned out to be one of the
smaller challenges patents in face while
bringing this new iteration of the Caped
Crusader to life during a global
pandemic
Jeremy Renner was in the news in early
2023 after getting injured saving his
nephew from being crushed but this
real-life Hero has also made a name for
himself by doing his own stunt work and
sometimes these stunts result in
injuries Renner discussed his commitment
to doing his own stunts with Howard
Stern you don't want him to like be
pulled out of a movie because you know
see some guy with a bad wig trying to do
the stunt this incurs a major price tag
however Renner broke both his arms while
filming the action comedy tag
astonishingly he went back to work the
same day Renner has gotten beaten up
while playing Hawkeye too while filming
is stunt for The Avengers the actor tore
a muscle in his back and had to take a
break from filming director Joss Whedon
told The Hollywood Reporter his fight
work is wonderful precise heroic and you
seldom have to double him but one day he
just turned wrong and his whole body
shut down he was in enormous pain and we
had to shut that sequence down and shoot
it a couple of weeks later
Ruby Rose sustained a spinal injury
while filming the first season of
Batwoman the actor had surgery for two
herniated discs sharing on Instagram a
couple of months ago I was told I needed
an emergency surgery or I was risking
becoming paralyzed I had herniated two
discs doing stunts and they were close
to severing my spinal cord I was in
chronic pain and yet couldn't feel my
arms after this injury Rose completed
filming season 1 and a part of the
series according to vulture she later
alleged that she was pressured to return
to production only 10 days after surgery
and that the CW production was unsafe
yeah you know it stings a little just
just stuff for reference
Warner Brothers television group denied
Rose's allegations and claimed the actor
was let go due to colleagues complaints
notably Rose isn't the only actor who
was hurt on set a production assistant
was left paralyzed after being injured
by a descending lift we may never know
the truth about the set of Batwoman but
we do know that Rose required surgery
for injuries sustained while playing the
titular character
while filming black panther wakanda
forever in Boston Leticia Wright who
plays shuri suffered a concussion and a
shoulder fracture initially no one
expected Wright's injuries to affect the
production of the Blockbuster Marvel
movie but in November 2021 production on
the Black Panther sequel was temporarily
halted so Wright could recover after
Chadwick boseman's tragic death Marvel
decided not to recast the role of
t'challa this meant shuri embarked on a
larger role in the sequel eventually
taking on the mantle of the Black
Panther herself because of this
increased profile the production needed
to give right now the star ample time to
heal from her injuries like many movies
filmed during the pandemic black panther
wakanda forever also experienced several
delays and setbacks in addition to being
subject to ever shifting regulations
this forced everyone involved to be
flexible Marvel Studios Executives sent
a note to the cast and crew of the
production detailing the need for a
delay in filming it read Leticia had a
frightening accident on our set during a
stunt back in August it was a reminder
of the importance of safety at all times
in our work which we know you understand
and are committed to what we had
initially thought were minor injuries
turned out to be much more serious
happily Wright was able to recover and
black panther wakanda forever made it to
theaters
in very rare circumstances something
worse than serious damage befalls actors
tragically this is what happened to
Brandon Lee when he was filming the crow
in 1993. the crow follows the titular
hero an avenging angel with goth Rock
Swagger as he seeks revenge for his own
death
suddenly I heard a tapping as of someone
gently wrapping wrapping at my chamber
door
during production Lee was shot with a
prop gun that accidentally contained the
tip of a dummy round in the barrel of
the firearm he died about 12 hours later
his death raised major concerns about
firearm safety in the film industry and
remains one of the saddest Hollywood
stories of the past few decades District
Attorney Jerry Spivey declined to press
charges against the movie's production
company as he told the New York Times
there's a part of me that wants to file
charges and have a trial but from a
purely legal point of view I would not
feel comfortable Lee's mother Linda Lee
Cadwell filed a civil suit and settled
out of court Paramount Pictures backed
out of Distributing the film because of
Lee's death but it made 94 million
dollars at the box office and gained a
cult following in an eerie example of
Life imitating art Lee like his
character was young talented and on the
cusp of stardom when his life was cut
short he will always be remembered for
his role in The Crow
[Music]